the jurgen experience are you done are
you done fighting 100
i'm done you're done i'm done 100
and
it was hard for me to get out after
being in there for 20 years and that's
your identity yeah you know
and and then i just kind of
got into trying to be a father
you know and i was doing that thing try
to be around more
and then
and then all this stuff happened and i
find myself in here but i do think all
the blood all the tears all the sweat
all the
all the ups and downs all the good media
all the bad media all of that was to
prepare me
for for you know for this kind of you
know i i i see like everything that
they're going to throw at me i can kind
of see like well i kind of been through
that yeah
[Laughter]
yeah
the mental warfare
the mental warfare that a fighter has to
go through i mean my god there's nothing
like it in all sports and
you know when i first got decided to get
into this
i was like
you know
i i haven't i have i was just retired so
i wasn't trying to keep my everything
you know perfect in public and this and
i was just running around trying to i
was just a guy
trying to come off of a 20-year
uh journey of being the baddest man on
the planet
and then i
so it was tough it was really tough to
get over
you know that identity so as as time
went you know i was just living my life
some more ups and downs i like i say you
know
sometimes i was judged fairly other
times i wasn't you know and well bj when
you were on top you were one of the
baddest [ __ ] on earth you
really were you were a guy who went all
the way up to heavyweight to fight leota
machida
i mean it's i remember that fight
i mean you did some wild [ __ ] dude and
you were strangling a lot of [ __ ]
people man and for jiu jitsu guys like
for all my jujitsu guys you were the
[ __ ] man because you were a smaller
guy who choked out matt hughes you know
who was so [ __ ] good at the time and
matt hughes was a tank
when you got his back and and choked him
everybody's like oh [ __ ]
people forgot
they forgot those times bj and you know
there was a run like the sean shirk days
diego sanchez days you were a scary
[ __ ] dude you were a scary
[ __ ] you were tuned in
when you were tuned in man you were
something fierce i always tell people do
you have to judge a fighter
by the heights they reached not where
they fell afterwards and or or the up
and coming fights you got to judge them
by the heights that they reached
you're like a guy like oliveira he's a
great example he's had some losses he's
been knocked out but you can't you got
to judge him by the height
now
you got to be accurate and then maybe he
can only sustain that for a few years
that that like fedor could only stand
for a few years at the tippity top of
performance yes you got to judge them
from that yeah i it makes me sick when
people judge them by their worst
performances you know for you
the your best performances were
spectacular you had some crushing
performances when you were training with
marinovich and they got you in tip-top
shape dude you were terrifying when you
had that crazy gas tank man i i i did
i loved it you know uh one of the
morinovich uh
wait what's what's meredith
yeah but gary's at my house in hawaii
right now he's training some football
teams or something and he he has to come
down and it's great to have how did how
did that connection happen because they
basically changed the way you did
strength and conditioning right yes well
how did that how did this introduction
happen they uh
yeah how did it my brother met how did i
run into them
i forget how exactly but i think my
brother introduced me to them and
and when they they were just geniuses
man and no matter how good you are they
were 50 years ahead i remember we were
at uh in ucla or something and they had
that a little cone pattern and they had
me run it to see my agility and marv
said well that's too slow and the lady
said well how do you know and he said
because i made it up
these guys were just ahead of everybody
and they were the guys with the nfl
combine
and everything was speed because he
noticed that like the strongest guys who
had the strongest squad the biggest
bench press and all that they had the
lowest numbers on the field
and then that's how he started to put in
the agility the speed the movement the
the reflexes and going back so they were
they were really ahead of their time
yeah it was wild to watch man they
looked like they were torturing you
it was you know what looking back now i
see everybody and i look at them law all
who eats the most at the buffet the
hungriest one
and that's the whole thing no matter
what i'll look and i'll just be like is
he still hungry that's the only question
or does he yeah does he still want to
eat as much because literally a lot of
these guys they haven't ate filet mignon
before they have any lobster and they're
still thinking about what that's going
to taste like when they get when they
finally get the opportunity to buy that
for their family
yeah there's like a balance right of how
long you can maintain that hunger yes
how long can you maintain that ferocity
yep it has nothing to do with who's the
best it's who wants it the most that's
what it is and
that's what i thought about i mean i
kind of knew that about martial arts i
mean you go in there and
you be right as quick and as violent as
in and as intimidating as possible
when you get in there but believe me i
believe just like me even at my best i'm
like what can i get what can i do to
make the referee stop this how can i
make the referee stop this thing because
you're nervous right the hero in the
coward they're both scared but the
hero's gonna step forward
yeah you were a wild [ __ ] in
your prime brother you were a wild
[ __ ] you were fun to watch the
dean thomas fight there was a lot of
fights that were like holy [ __ ]
nothing else mattered to me in my life
at that time than than being the the
toughest and most skilled
martial artist on the planet and just
fighter i didn't consider myself a
martial artist i just thought of myself
as a fighter
i'll beat you up
you were certainly doing that man and
so when did you did you continue that
kind of strength and conditioning
routine or did you stop doing it after a
while
um
i people start to fall apart in
different ideas and coaches start to
fight with each other and
you know and
i
that's what happened with
with that stuff marv kind of went his
own way
because as you get six weeks out from
the fight your boxing coach is screaming
he's got a spar
he's got a spar
and then the other guy is like no this
is enough and then they start going and
then it
has a reaction on you let's explain it
to everybody because this is the
philosophy the two different
philosophies
the the marinovich's believe that you
already know how to fight
all you need to do is just get in
ridiculous condition
and so they were just going to put you
through that and what did you do like
light drills other than that like
hitting pads like what kind of stuff did
you do
but no sparring right maybe not even
pads
just different things speed a lot of
good stuff i would do ladders
we would do that water workout stuff
and they thought that that was more
important than anything
yes and it was very important i would
never say that it wasn't you know
and then on the other side
it's the same it's people say do you
coach you train i say no but if i did
i'll tell you what i would do i would
show up to the gym i'd tell another
coach that had his fighter and i would
say hey coach can my boy get a couple
rounds with your board up with your boy
tomorrow and then i look at my guy and
go kick his ass tomorrow and then i'd
leave him and make him go home and think
about it all night because the act of
the physical act of fighting that ain't
a fight it's the going home and thinking
about it all night long anybody can get
into a fight real quick in school but
when they say meet me at the park after
and the whole school shows up no that's
the fight
you know
or i'll meet you in four months
for a ufc card isn't that amazing that's
when it gets wild right when you're
planning these fights months out and
everybody gets to know that it's coming
yes
but that that's it sleeping with that
that is that's what it's all about
sleeping with it controlling it
internalizing it
you